earlier this year james edward mills did
something i've always wanted to do he
flew to nepal and directed the base of
mount everest
i did uh travel with the team um from
kathmandu to
from luke love then we basically walked
from lukewarm to everest base camp
wow man was that your first time at base
game it was my first time to asia
um yeah definitely the first time i've
been to everest base camp
james is a journalist who's covered the
outdoors for decades and he's been
following a climbing expedition called
full circle everest
okay mount everest obviously a big deal
tallest mountain on earth more than 29
000 feet above sea level
james wasn't going for the summit just
base camp but even that's no small task
rivers base camp is at 17 500 feet and
at that altitude you're right on the
edge of what the human body can handle
for any length of time
i think we get like like a light rain on
the way up you know
it wasn't anywhere near as cold as i
thought it was going to be
um it was every bit as steep as i knew
it would be and
lack of oxygen is a very real thing
hundreds of people attempt to climb
everest every year most of them
including full circle everest rely on
sherpas and other local people as guides
i've always heard base camp as like a
mini un people come from all over the
world to chase a common goal and there's
usually a little competitive tension in
the air but also a sense of a shared
journey
james says the full circle team really
felt like everyone was in it together
we had the punjab ceremony which
basically
is the blessing for
the
for the the client basically asking um
for spiritual permission to make the
climb to the summit
um the the
the environment was festive it was
jubilant you know i mean we had you know
people you know come up and you know and
share in all the food and and beer and
alcohol and just having you know a great
time chanting and singing and dancing
and you know really
having a celebration
by now there's a long list of mount
everest first
the first ever summit in 1953 by tensing
norgay and edmund hillary
the first summit by americans 10 years
later which was sponsored by national
geographic by the way
the first summit without supplemental
oxygen italian reinhold mester and
austrian peter hablar
the first in winter two polish climbers
chistop volitsky and lesheck chihi
the first to ski from the summit all the
way down davo carnitia from slovenia
yeah i know all this seems nuts but it
seems like if you name it someone's done
it
and yet there was one first that still
hadn't been claimed which the full
circle team had their eyes on
the first black climber summited in 2003
sibuso villani from south africa
but a full team of black climbers had
never reached the roof of the world
and not unlike every representation when
it comes to you know mountaineering
we're always going to count the first
american the first italian you know the
first you know uh
chilean i mean we're we're always going
to count this but we never took the time
to count the number of black people
you know and and i think that it was
very important that we did in such a way
that it was
representative of how we go about
defining ourselves not only nationally
but culturally
james knows of six black climbers who've
reached the summit by other estimates it
could be as many as 10 or 12. either way
that's a tiny fraction of the thousands
of people who made it to the top
so i personally felt that it was really
important
you know that we established a bigger
better conversation around
representation of black people when it
comes to high level
wilderness adventure specifically
the biggest prize which is the the
summit of everest
i'm peter gwynne and this is overheard a
show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at natu and
follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week we go inside full circle
everest a group of black climbers trying
to make history on the world's highest
mountain we'll learn about the adventure
gap that keeps many people of color away
from the great outdoors and we'll follow
one climber who wants to set an example
for budding black explorers to follow
we'll have more after the break
but before we get on with this episode
thanks for listening and if you like
what you hear consider a national
geographic subscription and get
exclusive access to stories published
daily curated newsletters and 130 years
of archives subscribe today at
natgeo.com
explore more
for more than 30 years james edward
mills has been a wilderness guide an
outfitter and then a journalist covering
the outdoors
and like a lot of outdoorsy people it
all started when he was a kid
yeah i grew up in los angeles california
and despite the fact that it's a very
urban area
we actually have quite a bit of nature
you know as a kid it was a monthly
activity to go camping or
skiing or climbing with my brothers and
the other
boys in our scout troop and so
as a kid growing up despite having had
very many positive experiences myself as
as a black kid growing up in southern
california
there weren't very many of us
[Music]
james says there also weren't many black
outdoor role models to look up to
so through his organization the joy trip
project which covers the outdoor
recreation industry he focuses on
stories that show those role models
he covered the first all-black team to
attempt to summit alaska's denali the
highest mountain in north america
at the time of this expedition in 2013
the national park service estimated that
less than two percent
of park visitors
were black and relative to our
percentage of the population that's
egregiously low
and
one of the things that i realized is
that there seemed to be a technical
divide between who spends time in nature
and who doesn't
james coined a term for this the
adventure gap
put simply black americans are less
likely to spend time in nature there's
many reasons for this but for starters
there's a long history of white people
preventing people of color from enjoying
the outdoors
in 1934 nearly two decades after the
creation of the national park system
franklin roosevelt gave a speech in
glacier national park where he said that
quote there is nothing so american as
our national parks
he added that the fundamental idea
behind the parks is that the country
belongs to the people
he went on to say that the parks help
enrich the lives of all of us
but when he said this jim crow
segregation extended to the outdoors
black travelers could be turned away
with signs that said for whites only
on paper all national park facilities
were desegregated in 1945 but in reality
it took years for some parks to welcome
everyone
it's ironic because so in 1953 when sir
edmund hillary summited everest
black people in america couldn't visit
national parks
and so you have this beginning of of the
modern mountaineering
era
and you have very limited representation
of black people in outer recreation
because of jim crow segregation you know
because of
very clear cultural social prohibitions
that prevented this access to nature
but even after it ended segregation cast
a long shadow
and many black adventurers are still
trying to stake out a place in the
outdoors
one person who's made a mark is a
climber named phil henderson
phil grew up in southern california a
lot like i did um you know he grew up
and had
um you know really great experiences in
the outdoors but also you know he felt
that he was not given his due as a black
person in the outdoors
ten years ago phil was actually part of
a national geographic expedition to
everest he's also led climbs of denali
and africa's mount kilimanjaro
i remember he told me a story once about
um you know working in a gear shop
gentleman's in the store looking for
some backcountry skis phillip walks up
to him and asks if he can help the guy
says no and then he goes to ask someone
else for help and that salesperson comes
to philip for advice because he knows
more about backcountry skiing than he
did now this person assumed that as a
black person philip couldn't possibly
know anything about
backcountry skis or mountaineering but
he he's had decades of experience in
this
a few years ago phil told james about
his new big idea
he wanted to send black climbers to
everest and not just one or two of them
but a whole team
if all went well his team would almost
double the number of black people who'd
reached the roof of the world
and he basically invited me to help to
document the story of the expedition and
truthfully it i became an embedded
journalist on this project and
that included being involved from the
very beginning so despite the fact that
i wasn't actually a climber on this
expedition i was trying to play a role
to help
guide its course while still reporting
on it
one thing i've learned about mount
everest is that unless your name is
reinhold messner or goran crop epic
swedish adventurer look him up
you don't climb the world's highest
mountain alone
there are sherpa hauling gear and oxygen
bottles and setting ropes you've got
staff at base camp cooking hot meals and
making sure all the gear works you've
got experts sending weather forecasts
and medical advice
and sometimes you just need support
someone who's got your back on this
all-consuming endeavor
as phil henderson started putting
together his team of black climbers he
heard from conrad anchor an old friend
and a world-class mountaineer
conrad has summited everest three times
including leading the nat geo expedition
phil was a part of and conrad has made
it a point to give back to the climbing
community
he established the kimbu climbing center
in nepal a vocational school that helps
train local guides in professional
mountaineering techniques in wilderness
first aid
all roads seem to lead through conrad
anchor
so how did conrad sort of get involved
in this whole expedition
it's funny that you put it that way
because i mean i've known conrad for
over 30 years but one of the things that
that conrad has been really supportive
of is
making the outdoors more accessible to
more people you know i think that he has
recognized his personal privilege but
also
you know perhaps the responsibility of
making sure that the outdoors is more
accessible to more people one of the
things that i really you know respect
him for is
he kept his role exclusively advisory
you know he offered support and
encouragement you know when
someone needed to be
persuaded to support the expedition he
put in a good word for us but he allowed
this expedition to happen organically
philip henderson did all the heavy
lifting you know and
and this ultimately made this an
expedition that
was 100
person of color led
how did they go about putting together a
team i mean you can know a lot of people
but climbing mount everest
is sort of a whole another project so
what how did they go about doing it well
you know and it's it's it's really
interesting because you know there are a
lot of climbing festivals you know and
after a while you know you kind of have
this
camaraderie circle because inevitably
you know when you see a black climber at
an event like this and you're a black
climber you're going to connect
you know you're you're going to
gravitate towards one another but
then again of course you know
who has the skill and expertise to do
vertical ice climbing
it's a very verified skill set you know
so there's not very many people who can
do that so you you know start
asking around so you know who's good at
ice climbing
coming up
phil henderson finds an ice climber
we'll meet one of the members of the
full circle expedition
and learn how he went from growing up in
brooklyn
to scaling frozen waterfalls
[Music]
putting together a high altitude
climbing team is a tricky business
first you have to have people with
specialized skills
who are extremely physically fit and who
can work together under really intense
pressure
and you have to be ready to trust them
with your life
and in dom mullins phil found one of his
guys
don is an amazing character and um
he's you know one of the few climbers
that i didn't know before we put the
expedition together
excuse me here because i just got my
food served so i'll be sipping a little
soup while we're talking
this is dom when james reached him dom
was in the himalayas training for the
climbing season
dom took the winding road to becoming a
mountaineer he grew up in brooklyn not
many mountains around brooklyn and he
enlisted in the army after high school
at the age of 19
he was
a recruit in the u.s army on september
11th 2001
and he literally
you know in basic training was was
plunged into
the iraq war
um and was deployed originally to new
york city to patrol the site of the fall
of the 10 point towers
but he was actually among the very first
ground troops that were sent to
baghdad and fallujah
after his discharge dom became an
anti-war activist he worked as a staffer
in the u.s senate and then he earned a
phd at the city university of new york
studying sociology
his military network led him to a group
called veterans expeditions a non-profit
that organizes outdoor trips for vets
dom started climbing mountains with the
group in colorado and he realized there
was a whole world he knew nothing about
i didn't have an understanding of the
ceiling basically
of this sort of activity
something that i've fallen in love with
thereafter which is ice climbing i
didn't even know that that existed at
the time
you know i grew up in brooklyn i never
even seen a frozen waterfall much less
thought about the considered the fact
that waterfalls freeze you know what i'm
saying
and i attended various clinics that
veterans expeditions had on rock
climbing on ice climbing on
mountaineering
glacier travel
i just continued to attend their clinics
until eventually in like 2015
an opportunity to join a denali
expedition that they were hosting came
about
on that 2015 expedition dom reached the
summit of denali the highest point in
north america more than 20 000 feet
above sea level
now he had a taste of extreme
mountaineering and one little taste
wasn't enough
in climber jargon denali is one of the
seven summits the list of highest peaks
on each continent
after dom conquered one of the seven
he started to wonder what his next
challenge would be
and it didn't take him long to find the
answer
you know in just even conversation with
people
especially people who had their eyes set
on the seven summits or whatever they're
like oh wow you did denali that's like
one of the hardest of the seven summits
you know
next would be everest and i was like wow
that's very interesting prospect
and then because of my relationship with
veterans expeditions and heading out to
highlight canyon every so often every
year to ice climb i had the opportunity
to make friends with conrad anchor and
then conrad dropped a little bug in my
ear about the possibility of this and i
was like wow that would be amazing you
know this is feasible
in the end phil recruited nine members
to join him on the full circle team
including dom
in all there were nine black americans
in one kenyan
ranging in age from 26 to 62.
but remember how i said nobody climbs
everest alone
the backbone of practically all everest
expeditions is the local people
particularly the sherpa they hold the
gear and supplies set up base camp cook
the meals set ropes
and guide the climbers all the way to
the summit basically they are the
lifelines in one of earth's most hostile
environments
for many years most sherpa working on
mount everest didn't get their due other
than maybe tensing norgay
stories about the world's highest
mountain basically treated them as
invisible
but now nepali mountaineers are showing
the world how skilled they are many have
opened outfitting businesses and take
climbers and trekkers on expeditions
throughout the himalaya
and last year an all-nepali team was the
first to reach the summit of k2 the
world's second highest peak and widely
considered the most dangerous
and they did it during winter a feat
many thought was impossible
nepalese people are amazing
sherpa are amazing
i've met some really strong nepalese
climbers
that really
inspire me
when you look at
sherpa here
in the himalaya you're like you know
these people are hard they've survived a
lot man and they're really
resourceful well you know what does that
sound like that reminds you of black
people in the united states hardy people
they've been through a lot and they're
crazy resourceful so you know
that's the same type of representation
that i'm cultivating for myself and and
hopefully contributing for black people
in the united states for how nepalese
people view them
so the full circle team made sure that
the sherpa were included in the story
like for example pimba sherpa who was
one of the photographers on the
expedition had been on
everest
to summit four times prior to this
expedition
you know so he had had a long experience
but what's interesting is that he has an
interest in becoming a photographer and
and a filmmaker and so this is actually
an opportunity for him to work on this
project with us to raise his profile you
know and so now his pictures with this
expedition are being seen
literally all over the world
in april the full circle team was in
base camp in preparing for their big
push to the summit climbing everest
actually takes several weeks you go
through a series of climbs and descents
to get used to the altitude
by this time james was already back in
wisconsin and was getting text messages
from the team on their progress
and when the 10 climbers finally set off
on their summit attempt he hung on every
update
i was really pleased to hear that they
actually had a target weather window
so that they could summit on may 12th
and the fact that the weather was so
well
predicted that that
you know five days before the actual
summit date they knew that this was
going to be their window of opportunity
everyone was climbing strong everybody
was in in
good physical condition so did they
encounter any obstacles uh like i mean
other than that it's mount everest
altitude is you know
you know will kill you alone etc etc but
were there any sort of setbacks or
or dramatic moments that you that you
remember hearing about
that's just it none
i mean there's there's there are no
moments of of um trauma or
or um
anxiety or any at least stuff that
they've shared with me so far
so tell me james where were you when you
heard they finally summoned it
you know i'm i'm sure i was either at my
desk at home or maybe at the gym or
something like that i mean it was it's
one of those things where it's like
birthing twins did they all come out
okay
some people will will climb faster than
others um some people will will summit
some people will stay at
the high camp and then summit later so
i'm literally waiting for dispatches one
at a time as people are coming through
and i mean as anyone will tell you
getting to the zone is only halfway to
finish the expedition
you've got to get back safely
[Music]
in the end seven of the ten full circle
team members assisted by h sherpa made
it to the summit
and into the history books and most
importantly every member of the team
came home safely
now that a whole team of black climbers
has reached the top of mount everest
james hopes the expedition sends a
simple message the outdoors is for you
too
here's how dom mullins put it
i think it does matter
particularly because in
the sport
mountaineering
people of african descent are are
underrepresented you know and and
underrepresented is a euphemistic
word
to describe
how scarce black people really are in
the sport
so
i think that by representing you know
black people
dedicated to
achieving something like this
exhibits a positive representation for
black people who may be interested in
the outdoors or who may be you know just
developing their skills in the outdoors
and make them feel like you know that's
a space
for them as well
it's a recreative space it's a
professional space
for black people
to aspire to as well
when i talked to james he was in denver
at one of the biggest outdoor retail
trade shows
he wants to help gear companies reach
black consumers
it's not that everyone has to climb
mount everest he just wants people to
explore a neighborhood trail or a park
at the trade show he was with phil
henderson and two other full-circle
climbers
people are stopping them in the in the
aisles you know congratulating them you
know they're posing for pictures
and um one gentleman in particular you
know said
to philip you know thank you what you're
doing for the culture
that level and degree of representation
is critical
because it's demonstrated to
an entire generation of black men and
women and their children that there are
no limits to the things that they can do
in the outdoors
in the 1920s a reporter asked british
explorer george mallory why he wanted to
climb mount everest
and mallory gave a famous answer he said
because it is there
the full circle team climbed everest not
only because the mountain is there but
because they are here too
and the next generation of black
explorers
is watching
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to natgeo.com
explore more to subscribe
you can also keep exploring with more
stories in our show notes we've got
pictures of the full circle team as they
climb to everest and check out james
podcast the joy trip project he also has
an extended interview with dom mullins
so you can go deep inside the mind of a
mountain climber with a really
interesting backstory
you can also learn about how people are
closing the adventure gap and read an
article by james about how the national
park service could make parks more
welcoming for people of color
also if you want to experience what it's
like to actually stand on the summit of
mount everest we've got you covered a
couple of years ago we used panoramic
drone photographs to create a 360 degree
view from the top of the mountain
it's the next best thing to actually be
in there and you don't even have to
strap on an oxygen bottle
that's all on the show notes they're
right there in your podcast app
[Music]
this week's episode of overheard is
produced by senior producer jacob pinter
our producers are kyrie douglas and
elana strauss our senior producers
include brian gutierrez our senior
editor is eli chen
our manager of audio is carla wills our
executive producer of audio is davar
ardellon our fact checkers are robin
palmer and julie beer our photo editor
is julie howe
ted woods sound designed this episode
ponsdale sue composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners the national
geographic society is committed to
illuminating and protecting the wonder
of our world and has funded the work of
james edward mills
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences nathan
lump is national geographic's
editor-in-chief and i'm your host peter
guinn see you all next time in the great
outdoors
[Music]
[Music]
you